Tyrese Gibson did you guys see the story
with Tyrese Gibson so he was a guy in
Fast and Furious
okay
friends with um Paul Walker
so what is he bold yes yes
him and his girl he has a girlfriend
now we can decide as a group is she wife
material just based on this clip you
know I know we don't we don't have to
say that we don't know all the facts you
know just based on this clip wife
material or not wife material
we linked up he wasn't my type at all my
type is actually Paul Walker recipes oh
my God
[Music]
he wasn't my type at all and my time is
not white I'm just saying I was more
interested in touch
and everything don't touch me
um
and
even when I met him I was like um he's
kind of old
uh
I just like his smile it's pretty cool
his personality this just went really
bad really fast his personality was okay
but he's getting off live he didn't
understand the Instagram model
um thing so he would always talk down so
you wanted the homie you didn't want me
um and that was that I wanted the whole
game to study he was cuter she said I'm
old you know all this already I wasn't
here type either so relax
and um yeah so now we're here it's like
an actual somewhat of a love story which
is crazy because I didn't know that I um
yeah no I'm done no no don't trust me
don't put obviously
okay what what's your initial reaction
to that that's so wrong I'm so shocked
Is that real then that was hard who they
weren't like pretending or anything I
mean who knows okay
who is wrong
and she kept going with it and kept
touching him when he said stop touching
me yeah
it was awkward pretty awkward to watch
wasn't it yeah it was horrible I was
cringing but also he looked so
embarrassed as well yeah I was about it
for him can you imagine can you imagine
if the rules were reversed and he said
you know she was kind of chubby not
really my type I wanted her friend
that would have gone down so horribly
yeah it shouldn't go either way neither
person should ever say that to either
person but yeah it would be it would be
in the eyes of society yeah yeah and
that shouldn't be how it's adapted
that's wrongful so she got a guy that's
hot okay let's just let's just be real
here man gorgeous gorgeous
allegedly he said he was faithful in his
life in his last marriage right so I
mean who knows celebrities right you
know
even on Instagram and saying she wanted
his friend yeah that was so by the way
he's alive
that was the worst part that was and the
fact that she went r.i.b no oh yeah that
was I missed so disrespectful on so many
different levels yeah and the whole
Instagram model comment it's so cringe
yeah it was trying to flip it though
wasn't it I don't know what she was
talking she was trying to Flap it she
was trying to flip it up and then yeah
yeah she was like oh yeah but you said
this yeah it was just trying to flip it
round on him to make him look like that
he was not having it it was so
uncomfortable it was horrible what was
your question about were you what you
just said to ask us
oh who is wrong yeah yeah
um yeah yeah she's definitely in the
wrong 100 there's there's yeah 100
that's just not okay why do we live in a
society where women think they can put
their men down on social media
so I think it's
have you have you ever heard a girl say
oh he you know he's he's just an idiot
or he's maybe not yeah I've seen it yeah
yeah well there's been this thing hasn't
there for a long time where guys on me
in the media like say Homer Simpson guys
on adverts guys in sitcoms are shown to
be the idiot you know the do first like
the fat husband who's useless and blah
blah blah and it's almost like a sort of
a meme Now isn't it where women it's
acceptable for women to say that kind of
thing but if a guy said something
similar to a woman that would be
completely yeah yeah I think because
women are meant to be the mature ones
you know that's the that's The Narrative
and it's like no a woman can be goofy
she can be a bit immature as well and
the guy could be mature than her but we
don't see that much if that makes sense
because like you said we always seen the
media that the guy's a bit stupid and
the woman's always like kind of yeah
she's always there like lecturing him or
being like do this do that and yeah
um it's just become acceptable that way
around hasn't it in western culture for
some reason I don't think I don't agree
with it it's not good I don't think you
should put your man down I think that
actually makes you you look bad and I
think it says more about you and your
character what she's saying that she's
like yeah yeah I thought your mate was
hotter but you know I kind of settled
for you I mean she's basically saying
like I didn't even really want you in
the first place I've just I'm just here
I wanted your friend but your friend
don't want me
yeah and he's dead as well which is
awful it's just degrading I didn't like
that yeah just that's awful I feel like
it's extreme feminist so that I've
turned that kind of narrative where
they've gone weak and say what we want I
think it's just because we're females
but
really you neither a person can say what
they want you have to have regardless of
what gender you are you have to have
mutual respect yeah the feminists have
flipped that and they've gone because
they don't want they don't want equality
I'm not I'm I'm equality everyone should
be equal but in retrospect so you should
only you it's like saying a goldfish
should do the same test as a bear like a
goldfish can't climb a tree you know
what I mean it it doesn't being equal
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
gonna do the same things or be able to
be tested on the same things but
feminists they want to switch the whole
narrative I think men and women can't
ever be equal because we're not I agree
no but biologically we're totally
different totally different when they
say are we want equality it's like what
does equality look like you want to do
half of the brick laying half of the
plumbing half of the electric
no they're doing loads of sewage
rebuilding aren't they in London at the
moment so maybe women could get on board
with that
I used to work in construction the
majority of the employees are men it's
like it's a party it's like I think it's
98 men in all those fields yeah the
women usually take on the admin roles
it's not usually the hard labor which
they're they're more most of them are
more than able to do it but they don't
want to I quite like that which is where
feminism comes from yeah
[Music]
um
I quite like that woman can have this
Independence
in a way but then I kind of but like I
still agree with
you know being that wife and staying at
home the housewife but personally just
to some extent I like to work as well
and obviously and
money and realistically the man is
always going to be making more
you know and I'm not on about like
job-wise or anything because it is equal
I'm on about you know like I've said
before like
um when I do have kids I won't be
working he'll be working
you know so
the other thing
um would you guys submit to a guy in a
50 50 relationship
so what he says goes
you're not going out tonight
if it's 50 50 yeah no sacrifice
but then there's submission submission
isn't sacrificed I'm not so it's not
it's not even that it's just I feel like
I'm a wife do you know what I mean so
I'm I'm gonna do what he says but the
respect isn't always going to be there
for him because it's just 50 50. why are
you asking me to bring 50 like you're
telling me you're not capable
of you know you need my help basically
and that's not attractive to women when
men say that here we go it's the burden
of performance again isn't it real as a
woman when a guy says like oh I need you
to help me with this it's a bit like
the one thing that was in the long run
most women are going to want to work the
same when they're older yeah so it's
like okay you know let's just say you're
in your 30s you're single right we're
not bringing the same youth infertility
that we used to bring so how can we
expect them to take over 100 of the
bills and it's like okay the next you're
gonna be with him the next 50 years
maybe you only work the next 20 and 30.
but he's probably going to work longer
than you
yeah
but I just I just lost the question
sorry would you submit if it's 50 50.
I don't think I would I don't but submit
as in like do what he says or so Matt is
like a boss
okay so when you go to work right I
don't know what you do for work on if
you work for yourself but you've had a
boss at some point or I think of it like
a coach right I pick which coach I want
right so and what he says goes I have to
listen to him at the end of the day you
know I might make a case occasionally
but you really can't do that too much
otherwise they're going to kick you off
the team or they're going to fire you
it's not your job
it's not your role to boss him around
yeah but our bosses the boss is giving
me you know a full salary so
of course I'm gonna listen to him and I
feel like that when when you're married
it's like if he's showing you that he's
going out and working hard and taking
care of you then you're like yes boss
yes yes yes leader yes leader yes my
king yes my king I cook for you I will
feed you I'll wash your clothes only
only one maybe two meals that we just
asked earlier
if he's doing 100 of the bills I'll do
three meals there we go that's my 10
percent
um but I just I think this is like the
mentality that's gonna leave a lot of
women single and half of us probably
because yeah because I mean there's only
so many like guys that can take over 100
of the bills we're in a modern time like
how can we expect them to take over 100
of the bills if we're not we're not
virgins anymore we're not young anymore
yeah I mean well she still is but but
you know yeah like the average area yeah
but the average age of first marriage
used to be like 22. it's 31 now here
um
but um I quite like being equal you know
like how that sense of power
um as well as the guy but um
if you think of it in a deeper way we
I don't know I kind of jump from one
side too I think I think what you're
saying is when you have children you
don't want to be equal that's what
you're saying isn't it obviously you can
oh no Wednesday I feel like when when it
comes to children and obviously like if
I'm a stay-at-home mom and like it just
depends on the situation
it's like
either way I'm the mother and you're the
father and I think
I wouldn't just listen to him if he says
this goes but you wouldn't you wouldn't
listen to him if he says something goes
about my child no because it's our child
if that makes sense but so it's 50 his
DNA 50 your DNA right yeah so if there's
a big decision how do you and you guys
disagree how do you make it uh again it
depends on the situation but
I'd always want to
like someone has to give in do you
expect him to give in or are you going
to give in
good question I always given
um
I think just like do good do good wives
submit to their husband's Authority I
don't think necessarily like if you're a
good wife or a good husband
um I think building that Foundation of
communicating well so if it comes
through an issue of anything and
obviously we're talking about children I
think it's just stating the facts
and then solving it so you both stated
your facts and you both disagree
who who gives in
happy wife happy life
[Music]
no you know it's funny you're not wrong
I mean that's I mean that's that happens
all the time how many women wear the
pants in relationships about to say
there's a lot of men who would literally
just do what their wife says and are
those women happy with them do they
always because they don't always
though yeah
as much as we want to see go ahead no
say what you're gonna say go ahead say
it okay as much as we want to be like
yeah
um I want to have a say and stuff that
there's times where sometimes you you
want someone to put you in your place
like I feel like so it doesn't make
sense for us to give in Ben yeah I can't
I give it yeah as much yeah
I
am so sorry uh yes because I feel like
when it comes to men I'm Gonna Keep it
nice and short because I can blub on
um so
we expect a lot from a guy obviously
when it comes to women being independent
which again I like an equality to some
extent
um we don't really give that sense
of power to like what means being a man
you know so like responsibility and
you know as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible